okay here's something that I think is
really cool but I also worried that
people are gonna be very angry about
because they'll say it's sjw PC nonsense
or something I don't even know people
complain about anything we do on the
show we had a voicemail on yesterday's
show from a female viewer saying I hear
mostly male callers I hear mostly male
voice mails and male names said as new
member of the day although today we had
Joe and Alice which is great is the
David Pakman show audience mostly male
and the answer was yet it's most shows
like ours have disproportionately male
audiences part of it is there's a lot of
male hosts which i think is something i
missed yesterday which a lot of viewers
very politely added to my valuation of
why yeah a majority of people on this
show are ma'am that's correct and there
might be just something about online
talk shows that are you know more
interesting to male viewers than female
viewers we don't know but that's the
reality our show majority reported Sam
cedar secular talk with Kyle kolinsky
The Young Turks disproportionately male
audiences so I got an email from Tom I
don't know if he wants his last name
said so I'll just say Tom Tom is it
david pakman show all-star he's a member
he has previously sponsored memberships
for other people he got in touch with me
on the basis of that voicemail and said
hi David once again I would like to help
your show this is already a great start
to a voicemail to get from somebody in
the audience this time I would like to
sponsor 15 50 % off memberships for a
year there is one caveat I would request
that at least ten of these memberships
are to females how that is handled
I would leave up to you it's just a drop
in the bucket but you've mentioned
several times that your subscribers are
predominantly male let me know if you
think this idea is even viable it is
completely viable and I don't know if
this is a sort of David Pakman show
affirmative action or what you want to
call it but we're doing it so we have 15
yearly memberships that includes the
bonus show it includes all the other
great membership perks normally that
costs you $60 a very reasonable rate I
would say even at $60 a great value Tom
will pay
thirty dollars towards fifteen
memberships for people you just pay the
other thirty bucks once you're locked in
at the thirty dollar rate you can keep
that rate for as long as you want renew
at that rate next year if you like the
only caveat is as Tom said at least ten
of those fifteen memberships are
reserved for female audience members the
other five can go to anybody and the
idea is to support more women being
involved with the show so how do you get
one of these fifteen memberships at
half-price email me david at david
pakman.com or use the contact form on
our website
I am personally handling these
memberships because Tom is such a
longtime trusted and important and
valuable supporter of the show we're not
relegating the administration of these
15 memberships to Pat were certainly not
delegating it to Noah he's that he's got
enough problems to deal with on his own
so Ann and Max you need way more than 15
memberships absolutely so I will handle
this david at david pakman.com what's
that talking about by the way I'm just
realizing he's not making I'm not making
heads or tails out of what Pat saying
here but Pat if I may I will handle
these memberships for people but I had
15 fans in the audience who you were
linking wanted a discounted membership
right and I guess they just don't get
one man they have to contact you instead
right we'll cut this entire back and
forth out of the final product for sure
david at david packard.com
or use the contact form at david
pakman.com let's get these 15
memberships spoken for and claimed
thanks to Tom very very exciting stuff